Although it’s difficult to find written
accounts, it appears that people have been
propelling themselves through the air with
poles since ancient times.
In fact, depictions of people leaping with
poles can be found as far back as 400 BC.
A practical and inexpensive way to traverse
swampy marshy areas, propelling over wet places
on poles has traditionally been a common practice
in the fens of Cambridgeshire, Lincolnshire,
Norfolk and Huntingdonshire, UK, as well as
the marshes of the Netherlands.
As the bogs and estuaries were drained and
developed, it became custom for residents
to keep jumping poles for use while walking
around outside.
Not restricted to the countryside, vaulting
water with poles has also been a popular technique
employed by Venice’s gondoliers, when moving
from their watercraft to shore.
Over the years, pole vaulting changed from
being a pragmatic mode of transportation to
a sport.
In 1843, the idea of competing for height
as opposed to distance was pioneered at an
early contest at Ulverston Football and Cricket
Club in Lancashire.
By 1850, competitions in the sport were being
held routinely in Germany, and by the mid-19th
century, the techniques we see today were
already in use in the U.S.
Although the poles were formerly made of aluminum
or bamboo, by the 1950s, modern composites
such as fiberglass were substituted – making
for a stronger, yet equally light, pole that
enabled vaulters to reach even greater heights.
However, there was one very significant change
to the sport that happened only relatively
recently.
In the early 1980s, five-time All-American
from Indiana University, Dave Volz, perfected
a technique of steadying the cross-bar during
a jump.
Volz was burly for a pole vaulter, at 185
pounds, and according to his friends, he would
“go down that runway so hard he’s almost
out of control.”
Having quick reactions while sailing through
the air, if he happened to hit the cross bar,
Volz would “reach out with his left hand,
grab the bar and steady it on the standards
while suspended in midair.”
Giving himself a distinct advantage, “Volzing”
allowed Volz to try for ever greater heights,
and set new records.
Having good success early, he raised the American
record twice in 1982 (to 18′ 10.5″), but
injuries that year to his left ankle had a
lasting effect.
Unable to make the Olympic team in 1984 and
1988 (he broke his right leg in multiple places
in 1987), Volz surprised everyone when he
finally made the U.S. Olympic Team in 1992
– and took fifth place.
Not everyone was impressed with his gymnastics,
however, and some of his competitors even
claimed that Volzing, “ruined” the sport,
even though it required incredible skill that
few could reliably emulate, perhaps making
the sport even more challenging.
In the end, many apparently agreed with the
opponents of Volzing, and today, it has been
banned by every main athletic association
including the International Association of
Athletics Federations (IAAF), the National
Collegiate Athletic Association (NCAA), the
National Federation of State High School Associations
(NFHS), and USA Track & Field, Inc.
(USATF), whose Rule 183(5)(d) provides:
It shall be a failure if . . . during the
vault, the vaulter steadies or replaces the
bar
with his/her hand(s).